et notre invité ce matin c'est Joël
Mergy bonjour merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes
président du Consistoire de Paris et
d'île-de-fance on est ravi de vous
recevoir en ce jour d'hommage national
Emmanuel Macon qui préside donc cet
hommage national aux victimes françaises
de l'attaque du Hamas en Israël c'était
le 7 octobre dernier un hommage qui
arrive donc 4 mois après l'attaque
est-ce que vous dites il était temps oui
c'était un hommage qui était attendu euh
par les les les familles des victimes
euh françaises de du massacre et du
pogrome du 7 du 7 octobre c'est attendu
par la communauté juif c'était attendu
par la communauté nationale je crois que
cétait c'était un un hommage attendu oui
il était temps et c'est bien qu'il ait
lieu il arrive un peu tard pour vous
écoutez on va pas euh on on l'a on l'a
demandé à plusieurs reprises
c'est-à-dire qu'on espérait qu'il arrive
plusut tôt maintenant il est là
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est important
de de respecter ce temps d'hommage les
familles sont là les les familles des
des victimes sont arrivés hier je pense
que le respect que nous leur devons pour
la dignité qu'ils ont montré fait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un c'est un jour
effectivement de deuil de recueillement
dommage et nous allons accompagner c'est
ce moment avec beaucoup de dignité
arrivé en provenance d'Israël he par un
vol spécial qui a été affraité en
pourquoi cette journée est importante
pour les familles qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour
elle je je pense que euh dans dans le
drame qui a été vécu euh par le peuple
juif par l'État d'Israël par ce ce po
gros mais cette attaque terroriste du 7
octobre c'est
important pour ces ces familles de façon
générale toutes les familles
israéliennes qui ont été touché mais
particulièrement les familles françaises
puisque c'est d'elles qu'on parle
aujourd'hui que que la France euh
reconnaissent euh le le le Hamas comme
une organisation terroriste et qu'elle
soit au côté de ses familles et d'Israël
dans son combat euh contre l'islamisme
radical et contre le terrorisme je crois
que c'était euh c'est important et puis
c'est important pour la reconnaissance
de de de ces de ces victimes de ces
blessés de ces otages qui sont encore
euh dont on attend encore des euh des
des nouvelles dont on espère la
libération c'est peut-être aussi
important vous allez nous le dire de de
sentir le soutien d'une nation est-ce
que vous vous êtes senti suffisamment
soutenu depuis le 7
octobre on s oui on s'est senti soutenu
je pense que la la position immédiate du
du du gouvernement des des du président
de la République la d'une majorité de de
la nation française de de des des élus
français de la société française a été
présente il y a toujours uni
malheureusement c'est j'espère c'est une
majorité mais il y a malheureusement une
minorité agissante celle qui n'a pas
reconnu le le le mouvement ramas comme
un mouvement terroriste il y a les les
absents les silencieux j'ai souvent fait
appel au aux artistes au monde aux
personnalités du monde de la culture à
tous ceux qui sont paradoxalement rester
trop silencieux face au DRAM que qu'a
vécu Israël que vit Israël depuis
plusieurs mois que vit Israël depuis
plusieurs décennies au drame du du
peuple juif pour à la remontée de
l'antisémitisme je pense qu'il y a eu
effectivement des des réactions il y a
eu effectivement des soutiens mais il y
a aussi eu des silences ou des
déclarations qui a été contre-productive
de la part alors vous nous parlez des
artistes du monde de la culture mais de
qui d'autrre de qui d'autre vous auriez
aimé du soutien et vous vous déplorez
aujourd'hui le
silence écoutez je je je pense d'abord
que tous les élus ne se sont pas
exprimés que la position de de des élus
de la France insoumise a été
insoutenable est encore insoutenable
aujourd'hui pour la communauté juive
pour Israël et et pour nos démocratie on
ne peut pas on ne peut pas avoir laisser
dire ou pouvoir laisser dire sans que je
puisse réagir aujourd'hui laisser penser
que le le le Hamas aurait une certaine
légitimité à s'attaquer à des Juifs à
Israël donc tout cela ça ça crée un
moment difficile et
puis le 7
octobre le drame le plus absolu
concernant le peuple juif depuis la Choa
apparaît au au sud
d'Israël le 8 et le 9 octobre on a en
France une poussée d'acte antisémite
comme jamais vu depuis de très
nombreuses décennies c'est-à-dire qu'au
lieu d'un mouvement d'empathie dans
notre société on a vu une libération des
pulsions antisémites les plus horrible
qu'il y a pu avoir alors oui
effectivement je je je veux voir le côté
positif de toutes les réactions
positives qu'il y a eu mais je dois
aussi dénoncer le côté négatif de toutes
les réactions qu'il n'y a pas eu ou des
réactions qui qui complètement indécente
qu'il a pu avoir à ce même moment on va
revenir sur cette montée de
l'antisémitisme évidemment mais sur
l'hommage vous parliez des élus LFI
certains sont présents quatre d'entre
eux seront présents aujourd'hui malgré
la demande de plusieurs familles de
victimes à ce qu'il n'assiste pas à cet
hommage est-ce que vous regretter que
néanmoins la France insoumise et
maintenu sa présence oui bien sûr oui
bien sûr on on ne peut pas avoir sous
une forme ou sous une autre donner une
forme de
justification aux attaques du mass en ne
dénonçant pas à ce jour encore 4 mois
après cela comme un mouvement terroriste
en ayant même dit que ce n'est pas des
juifs qui ont été assassinés mais des
Israéliens faisant la différence entre
des Israéliens et des Juifs alors que la
charte du Hamas elle parle de yahoudde
yahoud ça veut dire des Juifs elle ne
parle pas d'Israélien le Hamas veut
s'attaquer aux Juifs il veut s'attaquer
aux infidèles il veut s'attaquer au
monde libre donc quand quand on quand on
a
l'indécence de quelque part les laisser
penser que c'est de la résistance ce
qu'a fait le Hamas on ne pourrait avoir
la dessence de ne pas être présent dans
de face à à aux familles des victimes
qui ont souffert de ces déclarations qui
ont souffert de ce manque de
reconnaissance qui souffre aujourd'hui
qui viennent à laquelle la France veut
rendre
hommage je crois que c'est une une
volonté encore une fois d'apparaître à
un moment où il vaut mieux disparaître
même si eux disent qu'ils ont toujours
condamné ces attaques pour vous vous
nentendez pas ça non non je je n'entends
pas condamner on condamne toujours quel
quel est le citoyen du monde qui ne va
pas condamner des assassinats mais on a
pu laisser penser que tu es mes cousins
en Israël que tu es des enfants
assassiner des enfants décapité violer
des femmes une femme a été violée par 27
personnes différentes
éventré des femmes enceintes brûl des
corps c'est de la résistance on a pu
laisser penser c'est ça dans le monde
dans lequel nous vivons et ces
personnes-là veulent être face aux
personnes qui ont perdu dans ces
conditions leurs êtres les plus
chers c'est une insulte c'est une
insulte aux Juifs c'est un une insulte à
Israël c'est une insulte à la résistance
la résistance ce n'est pas prendre un
bébé et le et le faire le faire aotage
c'est une insulte au à la majorité du
monde musulman qui ne peut pas se
reconnaître dans ce massacre terroriste
du Hamas c'est fondamental que toutes
les forces de notre société cette
société que j'aime dans laquelle je vis
cette France dans laquelle je vis c'est
fondamental qu'il n'y ait plus une
personne qui considère que ça peut être
de la résistance et que ça peut être
autre chose que du que du terrorisme
c'est du terrorisme c'est une volonté
d'aniler un peuple c'est une volonté 80
ans après la choix de détruire le peuple
juif l'État juif c'est il faut le dire
clairement pour pouvoir bien combattre
ce mal certaines familles de victimes
accusent euh la France insomise de
porter une très lourde responsabilité
dans l'explosion de la judéophobie dans
le pays est-ce que vous aussi vous
pensez ça je pense que en en ne
condamnant pas cela on peut laisser
penser que s'attaquer à Israël ou à des
Israéliens qui sont des Juifs c'est
légitime et donc ça peut désinhiber ceux
qui veulent s'attaquer à des Juifs qui
ne sont pas des Israéliens quand dans un
foyer on fait l'amalgame de
l'antiionisme on récolte chez ses
enfants de
l'antisémitisme vous en parliez on a
constaté une montée très forte des actes
antisémite dans le pays depuis le le 7
octobre dernier le CRIF pointe une
augmentation de plus de 1000 % des actes
antisémites est-ce que aujourd'hui vous
vous sentez en sécurité en
France je crois quand on est juif on
sait qu'on a on connait on a le poids de
millénaires d'histoirees de millénaires
d'histoire extraordinaire et de ménaires
d'histoires d'antisémitisme de porome
d'assassinat dans tous ces moments on a
cherché à continuer à vivre normalement
malgré l'insécurité je sais que le
gouvernement le ministère de l'Intérieur
prend toutes les mesures pour essayer
d'assurer toute la sécurité de nos sites
toute la sécurité des personnes c'est
clair qu'on arrivera pas on va pas
mettre un un policier derrière chaque
Juif et c'est clair que le climat
d'antisémit le climat d'insécurité je
tourne dans les communautés je vois les
Juifs je vois la communauté juive ce
climat d'insécurité il existe il existe
en France il existe en Europe la montée
de l'antisionisme et la libération de la
parole antisioniste qui devient
finalement une nouvelle parole
antisémite à à libérer des actes et
effectivement il y a un climat
d'insécurité je me suis refusé dès le
début à dire que les Juifs ont peur
parce que je ne veux plus penser qu'il
puisse y avoir un monde où les Juifs ont
peur et si les Juifs ont peur en France
alors quel est l'avenir de notre pays
donc je crois qu'il faut
aujourd'hui y a une vigilance qu'il y a
effectivement des inquiétudes il y a
aussi et et c'est mon ma responsabilité
de le dire particulièrement ici et
particulièrement aujourd'hui beaucoup de
Juifs qui s'interrog sur leur avenir
beaucoup de Juifs qui qui qui ont la
tentation de Laalia Laalia c'est de
partir vivre en Israël vous rendez
compte le paradoxe Israël est en guerre
il y a des morts tous les jours et des
Juifs français pensent aller vivre en
Israël ça veut dire dire qu'il y a
aujourd'hui un climat d'interrogation
que j'ai vécu à plusieurs reprises dans
ma mission tant président du Consistoire
en à la suite des différents attentat
qui qui ont pu avoir lieu depuis
Toulouse depuis l'analimie jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il y a un paradoxe il y a un
réveil d'identité il y a une volonté
aussi de soutenir les l'État juif qui se
bat pour la survie du peuple juif mais
pour la survie du monde libre pour la
survie de l'humanité parce
qu'aujourd'hui le l'islamisme radical
c'est une attaque frontale contre Israël
mais on le sait c'est dans sa charte la
volonté de s'attaquer aux infidèles et à
l'ensemble des démocraties donc je je
crois que c'est effectivement il y a un
climat d'inquiétude mais il y a une vie
une vie juive qui continue je peux vous
l'assurer en tournant dans l'ensemble de
nos communautés les VI continuent à
vivre normalement c'est encore le cas
cette volonté parce que on avait eu un
entretien ensemble au moment de
l'hypercacher après les attentats de
l'hypercacher où vous me parliez
justement de cette tentation pour de
nombreux Français d'aller vivre en
Israël et même de ces nombreux Français
de confessions juifes qui étaient partis
en Israël est-ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
encore le cas comp tenu de la situation
on est dans la même situation il y a des
Français de confession juifes qui se
disent ben je préfère partir en Israël
malgré la situation là-bas plutôt que
d'être en franceou oui je suis je je je
je dois je dois le dire oui oui il y a
des Français de confession juives qui
malgré la situation ont envie d'aller
vivre en Israël j'ose espérer que c'est
par idéal ou par envie de retrouver des
membres de la famille beaucoup de
familles ont été touché on le voit quand
on voit 42 victimes on ne pense pas à
tous les blessés à à toutes les familles
qui qui sont issu de famille française
mais de façon plus générale à à d'autres
personnes qui sont touchées oui il y a
cela et il y a parallèlement notre
responsabilité j'ai j'ai pris la
responsabilité au lendemain on par
l'hypercacher de de de construire à
Paris un grand centre européen du
judaïsme c'est-à-dire de continuer à
mener la vie juive en France en ayant
confance confiance en la France c'est
fondamental pour nous aussi c'est vrai
que la montée des extrêmes c'est vrai
que ces déclarations notamment de la
France insoumise c'est c'est cette
antision qui monte ça doit nous
interpeller ça doit interpeller les
Juifs mais ça doit interpeller de façon
plus générale l'ensemble des citoyens
est pris de démocratie et d'humanisme
est-ce que ça interpelle suffisamment
selon vous je le disais tout à l'heure
pas suffisamment pas suffisamment est-ce
que vous attendiez à revoir de tels
actes dans notre pays non non je je
pensais vous savez à Chac à chacun des
moments on on disait il y avait un avant
et un après on l'a dit après Ilana limi
on l'a dit après Toulouse on l'a dit
après l'hyercacher eu et et
malheureusement voilà encore une
explosion d'actes
antisémite on s'attendait pas à avoir de
tels actes mais j'étais très inquiet
quand j'ai vu la montée des extrêmes à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a un an et
demi dans dans dans les les dernières
élections j'étais très inquiet parce que
les les messages les les messages
libérés de de d'antisionisme ils
engendrent nécessairement une libération
des actes antisémites est-ce il y a
aussi la question de l'école parce que
selon le CRIF plus de quasiment 13 % des
actes ont lieu en milieu scolaire dont
une majorité au collège est-ce que ça ça
vous inquiète que des jeunes euh on soit
là ça m'inquiète il faut savoir que
beaucoup de Juifs ont enlevé leurs
enfants des d'un certain nombre d'écoles
d'écoles publiques à cause de cela donc
les actes qu'on voit c'est encore des
actes résiduel s'il y avait davantage de
juifs dans les écoles publiques il y
aurait malheureusement encore davantage
d' II ça m'inquiète sur l'éducation qui
est donnée à la maison par des parents
parce des enfants qui arrivent avec des
paroles antisémites ils les ont pas
inventé ils les ont pas vu à la
télévision il les voitent dans les
réseaux sociaux pour les plus âgés et
ils les entendent à la maison donc je
crois qu'il faut qu'on revoit toute la
stratégie éducative qui peut se trouver
dans les foyers et qui est influencé
aujourd'hui par ce nouveau fléau
international qui est l'islamisme
radical est-ce que ça pose aussi la
question des réseaux sociaux vous avez
rencontré Elon Musk il y a quelques
jours est-ce que il a pris des
engagements pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme sur les réseaux sociaux
alors dans ce type de rencontre on passe
des messages est-ce qu'il a pris des
engagements il a visité au Ju j'étais
avec lui à kracovi il a visité au juuit
il a dit qu'il avait pris conscience de
choses dont il n'avait pas conscience
qu'il a même parlé qu'il avait été naïf
sur un certain nombre de de sujets il a
essayé de défendre son réseau social X
mais nous lui avons demandé je lui ai
demandé de que son réseau puisse
participer à la la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme et contre l'antisionisme
dans le dans le monde il a clairement
expliqué exprimé son soutien à Israël et
dans son combat contre le ramas et la
nécessité d'aniler complètement le ramas
après avoir visité au juuit c'est
important pour lui de le dire pour
revenir à à la cérémonie d'hommage c'est
une cérémonie qui est placée sous haut
de sécurité est-ce que contenu de ce
qu'on vient se dire vous redoutez des
perturbations des violences lors de
cette cérémonie non je je j'espère que
non je pense que
euh
de la part de la communauté juive je je
dois le répéter avec beaucoup beaucoup
de de de force il y a toujours une
dignité il y a toujours eu un respect
euh on a eu les pires moments dans notre
histoire à la suite de tous les actes
antisémites on n pas vu des jeunes juifs
faire casser des voitures brûler des
drapeaux mais est-ce que vous redoutez
que des gens viennent perturber cette
cérémonie faire des violences alors
après qu'on ne soit pas content de la
présence de de de de certains élus qui
ont l'indécence de venir de de venir
pleurer nos morts alors qu'ils n'ont pas
qui ne les ont pas soutenu dans les
moments les plus les plus douloureux
qu'on a qu'on a vécu je le comprends
mais nous ne sommes pas des
perturbateurs nous avons t non mais des
perturbations venues de l'extérieur oui
écoutez je je le dis de façon générale
parce c'est pour moi important de le
redire notamment il faut bien P c'est
qu'après le pire acte antisémite qui qui
a eu lieu où on a entendu vous avez
certainement visionner les films qui ont
été faits vis fait par les terroristes
mêmees avec des des caméras Gopro pour
laisser des images des drames qu'ils ont
commis je veux redire ici combien j'ai
été choqué à ce moment-là par le nombre
de fois que j'ai entendu àakbar en même
temps que j'ai entendu des rires des
rires on voit un un jeune appeler sa
maman dire j'ai sur les mains le sang de
10 Juifs on est face aux actes les plus
dramatiques qu'on a pu vivre au
lendemain de tous ces actes en France et
dans Europe on n pas protégé les
mosquées on a protégé les
synagogues on savait que la communauté
juif ne fait pas d'amalgame et qu'elle
elle reste digne et respectueuse des
valeur de notre société de la République
est-ce que dans les silences dont vous
parlez vous regrettez un silence vous
allez nous dire ou pas de la communauté
musulmane et des représentants religieux
musulmans je regrette qu'il n''est pas
aussi
condamné le Hamas comme un mouvement
terroriste je parle de la majorité des
responsables musulmans il y a un certain
nombre de de responsables qui les ont
condamnés un certain nombre
d'intellectuels qui les ont contanés je
crois que c'est tout l'honneur de
l'islam de démarquer le alakbar de
l'islam Debar qui a tué des Juifs
pendant pendant ces actes barbares et
qui nous rappelle aussi ce qui s'est
passé à l'hypercacher où le même cri a
été a été lancé par l'assassin de
l'hypercacher ou l'assassin des enfants
de de Toulouse donc je crois que c'est
fondamental que les musulmans condamnent
le Hamas comme un mouvement terroriste
et qui n'ont pas suffisamment fait pour
vous ils n'ont pas condamné le Hamas
comme un terroriste je crois que c'est
c'est c'est c'est important c'est
important aussi pour notre cohésion
sociale c'est important aussi pour une
majorité de musulmans qui vivent en
France et qui ne se reconnaissent pas
dans ces actes barbares qui ont qui ont
pu avoir lieu contre contre Israël et
contre le peuple juif l'Élysée il y a
l'hommage national évidemment
aujourd'hui mais l'Élysée envisage
ultérieurement un temps mémoriel pour
les français morts dans les
bombardements israéliens de Gaza est-ce
que pour vous c'est justifié est-ce que
vous seriez prêt participer à un tel
hommage j'attends de voir de quel temps
mémoriel il s'agit je voudrais pas
perturber il est pas question pour nous
aujourd'hui de mettre sur le même plan
les victimes intentionnelles d'un plan
barbare pogrome assassinat dont je viens
de parler avec tout ce qu'on sait
d'intention de préparation de de de de
de de de haine qui s'est déchaîné avec
les victimes collatérales d'une guerre
et je voudrais voir de quelle victime
franco-palestinen on parle quand on tape
sur Google on trouve une femme comme
Yasmine
Znaidi qui est une franco-palestinienne
qui était qui vit à Gaza et et qui qui a
été condamnée par la France pour
financement du terrorisme qui a qui a
réuni des fonds en France pour financer
le terrorisme en Syrie et à Gaza
j'espère qu'il ne s'agit pas de ce type
de personne auquel on pourrait rendre
hommage aujourd'hui il sera également
éement rendu hommage aux otages il sera
question des otages durant cet hommage
national que sait-on de ces otages
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il y a encore de
l'espoir écoutez je viens d'apprendre
comme vous par l'État d'Israël par le
Tahal qu'il y aurait 30 ou 50 otage qui
serait mort c'est un déchirement de le
dire aujourd'hui parce que chaque otage
c'est l'espoir d'une famille depuis 4
mois de retrouver son fils son frère son
enfant on a parlé beaucoup du du plus
jeune otage firbi bas 1 an un otage d'un
an résistance résistance pour certains
un otage d'un an dans les jaules dans
les sous les sous-sols Palestiniens du
Hamas
euh on a l'espoir qu' qu'ils reviendront
et la douleur aujourd'hui d'apprendre
que peut-être que 30 ou 50 d'entre eux
seraient morts dans quelles conditions
vont-ils revenir on a vu dans quelles
conditions sont revenus déjà ceux qui
sont là des mois sont passés en plus
avec les les des des barbares donc qui
ne réfléchissent pas du tout comme vous
et comme moi qui qui on qui ont d'autres
d'autres facteurs de réflexion donc oui
l'espoir est là il est porté dans dans
notre cœur et il reste dans notre cœur
et nous espérons et nous savons que la
France mettra aussi tous les moyens pour
essayer de de faire en sorte de
participer à la libération de de ces
otages qu' soient français ou pas
français vous avez des des nouvelles des
retours de la part des autorités du sort
des otages français non je je je pense
que les les informations sont peu
nombreuses à part celles que je viens de
vous donner qui j'espère ne se vérifiera
pas mais malheureusement quand une
information est donnée par t elle doit
être vérifiée on a dû déjà prévenir un
certain nombre de familles
supplémentaires vous imaginez on
attendait 136 otages s'il y en a 30 en
moins ce que ça veut dire combien de
familles aujourd'hui sont dans le
chagrin et dans la détresse de savoir
dans quelles condition ils sont morts je
me souviens de parents qui qui disaient
je préfère que mon mon enfant soit mort
plutôt qu'il soit encore retenu en otage
tellement on sait euh les conditions
barbares de détention de ces de de ces
otages juifs et Israéliens parce qu'on
ne fait pas de différence contrairement
à certains qui voudraient dire qu'on
s'est attaqué à des Israéliens voudrait
revenir là-dessus on s'attaque à des
Israéliens parce qu'ils sont juifs
Anthony blincol le secrétaire d'État
américain est actuellement en Israël
pour tenter de négocier une nouvelle
trêve pour libérer des otages est-ce que
pour vous un cesser le feu est souitable
écoutez moi je je suis président du
Consistoire de Paris je représente la
communauté juive à à Paris en
île-de-fance j'ai longtemps présidé le
conshistoire de France donc j'ai le
sentiment de la communauté juive je ne
suis pas un diplomate israélien c'est
évident c'est évident n'importe quel
être humain dans le monde préférit que
cette guerre s'arrête il y a des morts
tous les jours c'est fondamental que
cette guerre s'arrête mais c'est
fondamental aussi que les deux objectifs
indispensable pour l'humanité soit
atteint que les otages soient libérés et
que le Hamas soit détruit parce que le
Hamas s'il n'est pas détruit c'est une
menace permanente pour la l'existence de
l'État d'Israël on le sait par c'est sa
Charre c'est son objectif c'est et c'est
une menace permanente pour les
démocraties dans le monde un dernier mot
sur l'avenir vous nous parliez tout à
l'heure de votre inquiétude face à la
montée des extrêmes on constate une
montée de l'extrême droite en Europe
notamment de l'fd en all quel est votre
sentiment aujourd'hui face à
çaz la la la position de la communauté
juive a toujours été dans le le rejet
des extrêmes que ce soit de par les
liens anciens avec l'extrême droite
ancienne version que ce soit la la
montée de l'extrême gauche aujourd'hui
avec ses liens avec l'islamisme je crois
qu'il il y a une il y a une inquiétude
réelle sur la montée des extrêmes et ce
n'est pas des
positionsort uniste par rapport
aujourd'hui à la communauté juive ou à
Israël qui nous fait aujourd'hui pour
l'instant changer d'avis je pense qu'il
y a il y a d'abord une réparation de
toutes les déclarations qui ont été
faites dans le passé concernant le passé
et concernant le négationisme et
l'histoire de la choix qui est
fondamentale ça veut dire qu'il y a une
réparation à faire quand vous
voyez quand vous voyez le rassemblement
national dans dé mararchees contre
l'antisémitisme est-ce que pour vous
c'est quelque chose
d'acceptable écoutez ça c'est c'est leur
choix de parti
je redis aujourd'hui que pour nous les
extrêmes ne font pas partie aujourd'hui
de notre de notre cadre mais je le redis
aussi bien pour la France insoumise que
pour les élus du Front national il y a
des des il y a un passif avec la
communauté juive avec Israël avec
l'histoire de la Choa ce paif il doit
être réparé et je je lance un appel
aujourd'hui dans un hommage une journée
d'hommage national pour que les élus de
la France insoumis s'il en reste deux ou
trois qui continuent dans leur position
que la majorité des élus reconnaissent
devant devant la peine des personnes qui
viennent d'Israël jusqu'en France à
l'invitation du président de la
République pour pleurer leur mort pour
espérer la libération de leurs otages la
guérison de leurs blessés que devant
cela qu'on reconnaisse enfin le Hamas
comme un mouvement terroriste et qu'on
reconnaisse aussi que dans l'histoire du
peuple juif la choix a été le crime le
plus abominable et qu'il n'y a de
négationisme possible ni contre
concernant la Choa ni concernant le
meurtre actuel des Juifs et la montée de
l'islamisme radicale merci Jo mer merci
infiniment d'avoir été notre invité pour
cet entretien on passe au club des
territoir